[Music]
it's been a great three year run for the
Grantchester
what do you feel a grand chest tour has
meant to the world of chess it's meant a
lot of very high quality events with a
lot of top players in the world and I
think a lot of variety for chess fans to
also see you know different types of
time controls events different formats a
lot of experimentation which I
ultimately I think is good for for the
game and for there's chess as a
spectator sport it's great there is some
really a really really strong
professional tour it's not like Grand
Prix so there is no you know you can
just play your best chess you shouldn't
care about the result in general so okay
the good result is good but it's not
about qualifying somewhere so it's just
to play against best of the best in the
chess world the most tough opponents and
it's a great experience and the greatest
challenge um I think the Grantchester
has meant a lot I think it's great to
have a series of tournaments with the
top ten top 15 players in the world
competing sort of in in a circuit style
whereas prior to that normally it was
just want one-off events so you have
events where people win and then there's
just the next event and so I think when
you have a circuit or a cycle of a
couple of events it's a very good I
think it leads more to Jean Republic
having a better understanding because
you have more events you have a clear
winner and so therefore I think it's
been very beneficial of course it's nice
to have a which cycle you know where you
know every event is being together also
with the inclusion of somewhat fit
events it it makes it for a nice mix and
yeah my hope is that it gets bigger and
bigger yeah it's it's an opportunity to
play the strongest tournaments of the
year
and it's kind of a special thing because
what we see throughout the years that
the organization is constantly changing
they're trying to improve they're trying
to have a bigger impact in the world of
chess so I mean it's something every
chess player wants to be a part of well
I hope it's the embryo the nucleus of a
circuit I think so far they've done very
well because they took the score of
London and st. Louis and built on that
so we've added several rapid events
Paris Levin and of course another one in
st. Louis and I think if this keeps
going along and we get forward more
tournaments in then this could be the
nucleus of a new circuit for the chest
spectator for the chess world in general
it's it's also very good a polarizes
chess and they they know what to expect
it's it's become kind of like the NBA
where you know when the game start you
know you know how it works and it's not
like random as it used to be it's a it's
a great addition to the calendar that is
their interest it's sort of a new new
thing and more professional than its
it's been it's been done before and I
was very fortunate to win the inaugural
tour and hoping to to to repeat in this
area
[Music]
you